if you can use this you can make a spare
key fob for your Honda Civic push the
brake pedal and fire it
up boom the engine started right up
isn't that awesome I'm Mike with Tom key
company I want to get out of the rain
and show you just how easy it is to make
a spare key fob for this 2016 Honda
Civic check this out now it's important
to know you must have one working key
fob that starts the engine so you can
use our equipment to make a spare this
is not a theft service that's why you've
got to have one key that starts the
engine because if thieves already have a
key for your vehicle they're not waiting
around for Tom's key company to help
make a spare come to tomsk key.com where
you can place your order and get a spare
key fob and programmer shipped out to
you
today okay find the QR code scan it and
get the app downloaded once the app's
downloaded fire it up you can go into
key pairing and it'll walk you through
everything you need on this little
programmer device and take and scan the
QR code no one side has a QR code with
the serial number the other side has
some helpful instructions so you want to
get the serial
number there we go few important points
you need a stable internet connection
you've got to have all existing working
keys for your vehicle so today we've got
two working Keys one with this green
keychain and one with the tile keyfinder
that pairs to your smart phone so you
never lose your keys again and then
here's the new key that we're going to
program this one's aftermarket
these two both have the Honda Logo and
this one has no keychain so here's our
keys that one
works this one works and our new
one does not work yet okay here we go we
need to select our vehicle we've got a
Honda Civic
2016 there we go
next okay it tells us uh asks if we have
a smart key yes we do
that new key looks pretty pretty much
the
same okay tells us we got to plug the
programmer in come down near the gas and
brake pedal look around till you find
this little plug and then plug the
programmer
in you'll see it light up to make your
life easier you might pick up one of
these extension cables so you can see
what's going on with the programmer a
little bit easier notice the green light
come back to the app we got to get it
paired match the serial number and we're
going to pair our phone to the
programmer okay pairing request yep we
want to
pair all right turn
blue and back green
again I'll warn you sometimes when you
plug these in there's an update that has
to be downloaded to the programmer it'll
turn red if it's doing an update
okay we're seeing some blinking all
right there turned red so let's wait a
minute and we'll let this firmware
update to the
programmer okay we're about 50% the way
there okay upgrade successful we see the
blue light come back
on still showing unpaired here see if we
can get it
paired there we go green check mark on
the app next all right we're up to
date so at this point because it just
did this update it may make US enter the
vehicle information again I backed out
we're starting
over okay here we go turn on the
ignition be before performing the
function okay so I'm going to start the
vehicle
[Music]
engine engine is
running I'm going to turn off my radio
turn off my
HVAC and be careful that I don't drain
the battery okay let's Come On To The
Next
Step all right communicating with the
vehicle now it tells us some important
things a paired key is required to
perform key pairing so we've got two
working keys today we're only adding one
key but if you wanted to add more you
can get up to six Keys paired for you
sometimes with used vehicles you don't
know how many lost Keys exist in the
world you might run into a limit based
on Lost keys that are with prior owner
or or lost or at a car dealership or
something all right so we got our one
key to pair let's start turn off the
ignition okay turn it off all right
place a working key in your vehicle and
place all other Keys away from the
vehicle so I'm going to keep this one in
the vehicle I'm going to take these two
and get them away from
it all right I only have one key in the
vehicle turn on the
ignition now I'm not pushing the brake
pedal but I clicked it twice until the
lights lit up on the dashboard tell this
key pairing is starting place all Keys
away from the vehicle so let me get this
one out of the
vehicle
okay place a new key in the
vehicle come back I've got the new
key to be paired let's click
okay turn off the
ignition gives us 30 seconds to do that
ignition off
turn on the ignition we got 30 seconds
click it
twice dashboard lights
up turn off the
ignition okay turn on the
ignition click twice dashboard lights
up number of keys paired
three well that was
easy turn off the ignition
turn on the
ignition two
clicks all right are the smart key lamp
and security indicator lamps turned off
turn off the
ignition turn on the
[Music]
ignition key pairing complete that's
success how easy was that took like five
minutes okay let's unplug this
programmer and test it
out with all my other Keys away from the
vehicle this is the only one that can
start the engine I'm going to push the
brake pedal and fire it
up boom the engine started right up
isn't that awesome we've got a new key
for this Honda Civic in less than 5
minutes in the driveway isn't that
amazing okay now I want to make sure the
other two key fobs still
work now this one is the only one in the
vehicle let's start the
engine yes starts right
up go get the third
one this is the only key in the vehicle
let's try starting the
engine excellent fires right up we've
got three working key fobs
now all right let's check all three of
these Keys here's one of the original
ones here's the next original one both
work and here's the brand new
one look at that three working keys and
save tons of money over the cost the car
dealership wanted to charge isn't that
awesome now you might be wondering how
do you get your emergency keyblade
cut this is important you want this key
cut in case your fob battery dies or
your vehicle battery dies then you can
use this to unlock the doors and get
into your vehicle you can also hold your
key fob up to the push button start to
start the engine if the battery has died
on the fob so what you're going to do is
be sure you add our optional Key by
photo key cutting service when you place
your
order if you add that after you complete
checkout it's going to ask you to upload
three photos of the key so grab your
phone
get the key set nice and flat take your
three pictures and upload we'll cut the
keyblade for your new key fob this is so
amazing I love how the key by photo
service makes it so your new keyblade
arrives already fitting your vehicle it
can't get any easier than that to make a
spare key fob for your Honda Civic I
want you to know we provide amazing
customer support so if in the off chance
you run into a problem while using our
programming equipment to make your spare
key fob reach out to us help atomsk
key.com we also provide a full money
back guarantee so if you run into
problems ship everything back to get
your money refunded if you have the
unfortunate situation of having lost all
your car keys I'm sorry I'm also excited
to let you know that we have a new
partnership that may be able to help you
go to our website find the all keys lost
page and get some help there be sure you
leave a comment down below let people
know how easy it was to use our products
to make a spare key fob or if you got a
ripoff price from the car dealership be
sure you leave that so people can know
how much money they'll save through the
help of TOMS key Company please like the
video and subscribe it'll help you find
it when you go to program your key it'll
also help YouTube spread the word about
Tom's key company to other people so
they can save hundreds of dollars on the
cost of a spare car key